well tonight bit of a date night for you
both how lovely is it to be here with
your lovely wife get out of the house
she looks great and to see ben and jayla
here together jayla won't just leave me
alone stop it
uh that was great
it's it's wonderful and uh i'm just
happy to see uh see my friend really
happy and to be out with with uh with
lucy tonight this is great and it's a
big moment in our life whatever happens
whatever the reception is it's that we
really love it and and that's really the
only thing we can control i don't know
if this is hard to believe it was hard
to believe for ben almost 25 years ago
goodwill hunting premiere now you guys
are here what do you remember about that
night do you remember it i remember it
really well uh i remember the premiere
here in new york was at the ziegfeld um
i remember my whole family was here kind
of like tonight you know um
and uh yeah i mean it's a big thing to
kind of have an idea and then write
something and create something out of
thin air and then it just it takes a lot
and you feel a lot of gratitude to the
the
hundreds of people who work on it and
and make it better and you know all the
actors i mean adam and jody are amazing
and you know yeah and you guys are still
here doing it it's pretty awesome
yeah if you told me 25 years ago we said
i'd be like we made it we're still
we're still working okay good
um gotta ask you some looks in this
movie you're rocking what we're gonna
call a medieval mullet
yeah
yeah then ben's blonde um what was the
maintenance like like did you have
extensions did ben have to dye the
eyebrows every day no they were wigs
they're really good wigs actually and
and uh the uh the idea behind them was
it all came from ridley ridley's
obviously you know he started as a
painter he's very very visual if you
look at his movies
every single detail is very uh
uh important to to him and should be to
kind of any director but he um he he was
he sent us uh pictures of those haircuts
and he was and he explained
you know to me he goes like look
my guy's still remembered as this kind
of savage warrior and he goes he strikes
me as the kind of guy who would just
sheer the side of his head and throw his
helmet on and kind of keep going and
like wouldn't care how it looked what
did the families and your ladies think
of your looks oh i mean they're like wow
that's what you look like i mean i have
a scar on my face and you know it's it's
a very it's a very uh it's a very kind
of unique and specific look and it's
supposed to just not look like i look
now and and and uh that's rugged well
and also like i'm not a fan of those
movies that
you know they're like a medieval movie
made in the 80s and everyone's got
feathered hair and like you know and it
looks like he's just had a blow dryer
yeah you know what i mean it's like you
go that
seems weird i'm like i think matt has
real dirt on his face this movie yeah
that's what we wanted we wanted it to
look like that like the people look live
really close to the earth and uh and
like they don't necessarily look good
it's gritty and the jousting scene with
you and adam is so intense what was it
like really filming that because i i was
on the edge of my seat wondering how are
you both not getting hurt doing this
yeah adam is really fit and he's really
young
so it was
it was it was a lot for me um but he
just he's such a pro and he just he
really puts the work in he's a really
physical actor too he really he's a big
guy he's a strong guy like
how heavy are those costumes they were
as light as i think they could make them
and have them look i mean they're so
they they were heavy but they really did
a wonderful job of uh our armorer terry
he was amazing and uh and our costume
designer jante she you know i i love the
look and i think i think that's where we
took a little cinematic kind of liberty
and uh you know had we done it the way
it actually looked i think we would have
looked like the tin man like
two of us kind of like wobbling around
but um but i i really like the way they
they took it i loved talking to you
earlier today about how you right away
you know we got to bring a woman in on
this and we have to do this the right
way how much have the strong women in
your own lives affected the way that you
view
uh you know the struggles that women
have and your sensitivity to them i
think it's that i think it's also
there's a lot of
just in the in the time in which we live
because there's been this kind of
democratization of you know i mean
we hear so many more voices right
there's not that gatekeeper thing we
just hear all these voices and people
are saying please understand me please
you know and it's it's really i think
change for a lot of us who make movies
the the
the understanding that it's it's not
it's uh you there people give lip
service to oh we need to hear more
voices but you like
people's experience shapes the stories
that they tell obviously and so we're
sitting there with this thing going we
have this really good idea but there's
no way
we could do this as well as nicole
hollison could do it right so like let's
call her up you know and uh and and
let's see
what happens if we all tell this
together and i'm really happy we did
because i feel like it really worked
[Music]
you